[Musique]
je viens du sud de la France sud-est de
la France j'ai grandi à au Golf de
Saint-Donat maintenant je joue pour le
golf de Cannes Mougins et voilà j'ai
fait tout le cours tout le cursus de la
fédé des pôles Espoirs paul-france Paul
France messieurs je suis parti un petit
peu aux États-Unis mais voilà je suis
rentré pour pour continuer mon projet
avec mon staff ici
j'aimais bien après voilà je suis c'est
pas le seul sport que j'ai fait et voilà
j'essaie de toucher à tout le golf ça
m'a un petit peu plus ça m'a un peu plus
interpellé voilà la pouvoir se prouver à
soi-même des choses et voilà pas
dépendre par exemple d'autres joueurs
dans un sport cos et c'est toujours bien
ça procure d'autres sensations et j'ai
vite été accro
après je passerai sûrement pro dans très
peu de temps donc ce sera continué à
faire la même chose à progresser tous
les jours et avancer journée par journée
[Musique]